Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today.
Will Sommer, who's a politics reporter for
The Daily Beast and also co-host of the Fever
Dreams Podcast about conservative media.
He's author of the book Trust The Plan The
Rise of Cunanan and the Conspiracy That Unhinged
America.
Will, great to have you back.
Speaker 2: David Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So, you know, we many of us have
seen the polls that came out over the last
couple of years, some which will make claims
like, you know, a fifth of Americans or of
Republicans or whoever believe some aspect
of.
Q And on beliefs.
And then, you know, you look more deeply and
sometimes it's the slightly less crazy beliefs.
And so it can be sort of hard to know like
what does it really mean when we say this
portion of the population believes this stuff?
And are some of these beliefs unique to QAnon,
or are they kind of coincidental?
So let's just maybe start with what is your
understanding right now of when we talk about.
Q And on conspiracies, with which conspiracies
are we talking about?
Speaker 2: Sure.
So, yeah, I mean, I think it might be helpful
there to sort of lay down the fundamental
belief of.
Q And on and then, you know, we can go from
there.
Yeah.
So I would say, you know, there's so much
crazy stuff involved in this, but I think
kind of the core belief is that the world
is run by a cabal of pedophiles, Satanists
who torture children in satanic rituals to
bring their blood.
And that this includes people in banking in
Hollywood and the Democratic Party.
So that's.
And the second part of that is that this moment
is going to come called the storm, where Donald
Trump is going to essentially impose a fascist
dictatorship on America.
But they think that's a great idea.
Right.
Execute his enemies.
And so I would say that's sort of the core
belief of.
Q And on so when we when people are polled
on, do you think that world elites are in
satanic cults and, you know, abusing children,
that's in the typically in the teens to the
low 20%.
When you ask people do you believe in Q and
on straight up, it's usually and you know,
I like to go with the most conservative estimates
here because as you say, I mean, when we make
it really broad, if we say, do you think powerful
people abuse children, sometimes, you know,
the answer is that's not an unreasonable thing
to believe.
So when you ask people, do you believe in
Q And on really kind of flat out, they typically
say 3 to 7%.
And so, you know, I like to go with that kind
of stricter definition.
But at the same time, when you say, you know,
talk about satanic cults more generally, that's
still a lot of people.
Right?
And that's a pretty crazy belief.
So even on on the lower end, we're talking
about millions of Americans.
Speaker 1: A lot of the the way you just laid
it out.
There are lots of similar conspiracy theories
by substituting just like one word.
Like, for example, the storm sounds surprisingly
similar to the Christian rapture that some
believe in, but just with like slightly different
details.
And then the premise of these satanic pedophiles
are the cabal.
Sounds very similar to sort of like it's Jews
who are the ones in control.
How how much is this a recycling of other
versions of these tropes and how much of it
is unique?
Speaker 2: Sure.
I mean, I think it's a blend.
I think QAnon plays on these centuries old
tropes.
For example, in the book I talk about how
so much of QAnon I mean, I mentioned the blood
drinking, right?
You know, that is a direct play on this idea
of the Jewish blood libel, this idea dating
back to the 13th century that Jewish people
were murdering children to get blood to make
matzo bread for for Passover.
Speaker 1: And that everybody knows it's just
wheat and water.
That's the beauty of it.
You know, why would you adulterate it with
blood?
Well, who would do that?
Speaker 2: Exactly?
And so, you know, this idea is set off all
these pogroms and all these murders.
And so it research is going on where, you
know, I think it's not accidental that so
many of the villains are Jewish people in
banking or the Democratic Party or Hollywood.
At the same time, I think there are some new
elements, such as this idea of this kind of
mysterious clue giver.
Q Yep.
And this way that it it repackages so many
old conspiracy theories, but in a way that
it feels fresh to people.
And with, with the concept of the storm gives
them something to look forward to.
So it's not just, you know, kind of mulling
over all this sad stuff, but it gives them
this kind of twisted utopia that they can
help bring about.
Speaker 1: Is there what is your belief now
as to whether there is a person that is Q.
Speaker 2: Sure.
So I think it's never been conclusively proven.
But I think the best argument we've seen for
who's behind.
Q and I should say all the people I'm going
to name have denied it.
Yeah, but that is laid out pretty effectively
in the HBO docu series.
Q Into the Storm, laying out that there was
sort of a random guy interested in conspiracy
theories who started it, and then it was hijacked
from him by the people who ran it, and the
father and son duo, Jim and Ron Watkins.
Yeah.
And you know, in that series, they there's
like a quasi confession from Ron Watkins,
but no one has ever come out and said, yes,
I'm Q But I think absent any other evidence
that's we can pretty much assume I think it's
fair to say that it's those two.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Ron Watkins ran for was it governor of Arizona
or was it a member of Congress?
I don't remember.
Speaker 2: It was a much more modest goal.
He only thought he could be a member of the
House.
Speaker 1: Member of the House.
Right.
And I mean, one of the creepiest auras surrounding
that guy of anyone I can think of.
And I don't think that the Q thing came up
during the race, did it?
Or now I'm not sure.
Speaker 2: Not in a major way.
I mean, really, when he declared in this primary,
it was and, you know, he had been living in
Japan for a while, this very kind of bizarre
thing.
You didn't even live in the district at the
time or he had just moved there.
And I think he had had this brief, separate
career apart from Cuba and not as like an
election fraud expert after Trump lost the
right.
I think he thought he thought, you know, maybe
I've been on one American news a couple of
times now I can run for the house.
And I talked to all these guys in Arizona,
these political operatives, and they said,
you know, no way, this guy's going to get
slaughtered.
And as it turned out, he did.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
When we hear sometimes we'll like, send a
correspondent to Trump rallies.
We have this guy, Luke Beasley, who's who
has been going and so on, and he'll talk to
people.
And very often people won't bring up anything
about Q or QAnon, but they will say things
like the current president is actually Trump
who's controlling the military or a JFK is
alive.
And sometimes you can tell they don't know
the difference between JFK Senior and Junior,
and they go, Well, one of them would be 100
and but it's all they're all very confused
and you don't know where they got this stuff.
When you hear people say that stuff, is that
connected to Q beliefs in some way?
Speaker 2: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think the key thing for people to
understand now that we look and we say, Oh,
you know, I don't hear about Cuba on that
much.
There aren't too many people like, out and
about with Cuban shirts.
At the end of 2020, Q told his followers to
stop saying they were part of Q And on.
I think the sense was that the brand had been
damaged.
And so instead to spread these.
Q And unlike ideas about the Cabal, JFK Jr,
all these different things.
Yeah, but just don't say, Hey, would you like
to learn about.
Q And because, you know, and so now even now
I have people say, Oh, you know, there is
no.
Cunanan There is.
Q And there are the Anons.
I mean, it's these kind of linguistic tricks
they use.
Yeah, but I think even for people who have
never seen Q Clues, this kind of stuff, I
think these ideas have become mainstreamed
in the excuse me, mainstreamed in the Republican
Party.
And, you know, a great way to see that is
going to these Trump rallies and these events
because whether it's y'all, someone like Jordan
KLEPPER on The Daily Show, you kind of just
tap a little bit and they say, Well, I don't
like the corruption.
And you say, Yeah, I mean by the corruption
that they say, Well, let me tell you about
Pizzagate.
Speaker 1: Right?
Right.
No, we've seen that.
We've seen that develop in real time.
It's often under 60 seconds.
You go from some benign comment to really,
really wacky, wacky stuff.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE had this moment around
the time that Republicans took over the House,
and she made it clear she wants to kind of
be on the inside now and sided with Kevin
McCarthy in the speaker battle where she very
kind of generically said, I fell for some
stuff on the Internet and it's happened to
a lot of us.
And it was interpreted that that was a reference
to some of the Q and one type stuff that in
2018 she seemed to be kind of pushing and
following.
What what's your sense of that change that
we're seeing in people like GREENE and Boebert
and others with relation to their association
with QAnon stuff?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
So in the book I get into it.
I mean, I think it there's varying degrees
of QAnon devotion.
On one hand, you have Lauren Boebert, who,
as far as we know, simply saw it as sort of
a cynical thing to not at and flirt with and
say, well, you know, and they got some interesting
points, but maybe it's not for me.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE On the other hand,
I would put in like the top one or 2% of Q&A
commitment.
When you read her old posts, I mean, she was
she knows more about Q9 than I do.
And I wrote a book about it, right?
I mean, she was like getting into these kind
of Talmudic debates about, you know, the origins
of different Q drops and saying, Well, this
is a fake one, this is a real one.
I mean, she was deep, deep in it.
And so now when she comes out and says, Oh,
I guess I retweeted the wrong YouTube video
or what have you, I mean, that is just not
true.
Speaker 1: When it comes to 2024 and we have
Trump as a nominee, and I think that there
are some in the media that are overstating
the competitiveness of the primary.
If you look at the recent polls, something
has to really change for Trump.
To fall out of favor.
And that could happen.
It could happen, but.
But I do think that it's not quite as competitive
as some might like it to be.
If we see Trump on the path towards the 2024
nomination, do you expect to see the Q anon
resurgence that we saw in previous years,
or does it seem like maybe MAGA has to a degree
move beyond it?
Speaker 2: I think we're going to see I think
there's a good chance that we'll see Cuban
art come back in a more visible way.
I mean, it's kind of been bubbling online
and and it's gaining a foothold again now
that, you know, Elon's letting that back on
Twitter and all these things.
Yeah.
But but I do think I mean, Trump is he's signaling
to Cuban on constantly.
I mean, there was one study that said a third
of his posts on truth social have been promoting
Cubans and you know either because like he'll
just he does it now in a way that he never
did during the campaign where he would he'll
just post memes of himself wearing like edited
to have a Cuban on button and stuff.
I mean, he's really out there with that.
And, you know, now he's implying that Ron
DeSantis is a pedophile.
He's posting these pictures of him partying
with high school students.
Yeah.
Could this be our, you know, our beloved Ron?
And, you know, others say, David, I mean,
this is the idea that this is not going to
be a competitive primary.
I'm with you.
I mean, something could change, but people
just you got to watch Ron DeSantis talk and
you think, I mean, this guy is going to go
up against Trump?
I don't think so.
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
Let's talk about that a little bit.
You cover these issues as well.
I understand you haven't announced and you've
got 30, 40% in some polls that that's pretty
remarkable stuff.
I mean, there's nobody's going to deny that.
The question is, by announcing, do you take
any of Trump's support or is it going to be
a consolidation of the existing non-Trump
electorate?
And I think it's it's sort of the latter.
And when I think about the complete lack of
charisma that DeSantis has, and he's sort
of expressed a desire to go high and not stoop
to Trump's level, which is fine in some general,
you know, vague, vague sense.
But practically speaking, I don't think it's
going to work the numbers in his favor, if
that's the way the primary goes, I think Trump
will just crush him.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, you see these and
these are all anecdotal things, but, you know,
there was recently that clip on Fox News,
which we know is trying to favor DeSantis.
Yeah.
Where Brian KILMEADE is in a diner saying,
yes, you know, primaries coming up, I need
to say ads here everyone goes, Trump trumps
up, you know.
So it's just I think, you know, you know,
he's going to have to campaign at some point.
I think he's kind of awkward enough that they're
going to try to keep him from doing much retail
campaigning.
But there's going to be some video where he
just looks weird.
And I mean, and then Trump's just going to
say, you know, look at me, Barron.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And by the way, not I couldn't care less about
this, but it's wild that in the midst of all
of the anti drag stuff, DeSantis seems to
regularly wear like high heeled cowboy boots,
which I know is a whole thing.
And like, it doesn't bother me.
It's just interesting how they fall into these
weird things where it seems like.
Is that going to help you, knowing what the
kind of dialog is right now with some of these
issues among the people who support Trump
to begin with?
It all seems awkward.
Speaker 2: It it does seem awkward.
I mean, there's also that picture of, you
know, Biden's hugging people and DeSantis
is kind of stumping by.
Yeah, I mean, it is.
I think basically what's going on is I think
the conservative intellectuals and media are
smart enough to realize that.
I think that Sanders would be a more effective
and potentially more vicious Trump.
Right.
I mean, if we just see the policies he's doing
or very or Orban ask, oh, yeah, you know,
he has all these conservative intellectuals
and I use that term lightly, like Chris Rufo
already is, you know, he's he's making university
trustees and stuff to really like kind of
crack the whip on these liberal institutions.
Whereas Trump, you know, he's president, he'll
be stewing over Graydon Carter again, you
know, getting in his own way.
So I think they want to do it.
But it seems there's no evidence.
I think the grassroots wants to move on.
Speaker 1: No, I think that that's that that's
absolutely the case.
The book is Trust The Plan The Rise of Cunanan
and the Conspiracy That Unhinged America.
We've been speaking with the book's author
Will Sommer, who's also a politics reporter
for The Daily Beast and co-hosts The Fever
Dreams podcast.
Will, always great speaking to you.
Really appreciate it.
Speaker 2: David.
Thanks for having me.